hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to consternation - if you
remember consternation one it was this
surreal game that was multiplayer
without letting you know it was
multiplayer it was this non-stop
terrifying chain of events that passed
down from Player to Player in a totally
bizarre and surreal and unexpected way
this is the sequel to that game I have
no idea how this game is gonna play out
but I know that it's probably gonna have
a surprise that I'm not prepared for I
don't expect it to play out the same way
that it did in the first game so well
okay oh cool kit alert fake yeah what
I'm sorry this is some SCP crap here
wait a minute oh oh I really get low
when Ludacris made that song Ludacris
was clearly talking about me um oh press
the right mouse button to zoom your
flashlight zooming your flashlight
increases how far you can see oh wow
yeah no joke okay Wow sex haha yeah nope
it's here whoa oh oh may I ask what is
here because that's important in this
discussion can I add some art of my own
Wow that's gross that's very gross all
right I hate it when horror games tell
me her sprint I don't want to know I
don't want to know how to sprint I don't
want to know that I need to sprint no oh
great why am I here you'd open the map
oh uh okay all right so I'm in the
bottom left I think I still don't know
what the point is gaming's after turn on
night vision uses battery once it's gone
it's gone I don't want to use that then
that sounds terrible why would I use all
that obsidian pixie magic okay were
those were those written by other
players or something hee hoo hoo
it's very weird I just don't know what
to expect I never knew much about people
until I took one apart
ah that's scary the truth happened nice
hot this makes no sense
goddamn God what God who who'd you got
alright um that's blocked off I know I
generally have a feeling of where I am
but I don't know what I'm going for
or why that's the biggest question I
have young wild and free huh
that ain't me something about this
doesn't make me feel free smash tunnel
all you talk about penis smashing yeah I
know
why I'm sorry you want to run that by me
again
actually you know what don't don't run
that by me again I don't need anything
run by me ever okay door hey d'Or good
great so we're stuck maybe all right
good great I get to go back I'm glad
about that that's a happy thing me I'm
happy about that that's good that is
very good that's the goodest thing I've
ever heard
don't do whatever you're about to do
don't do whatever you're about to do do
not do anything I swear
okay whoever explorers we're exploring
in debate just go ignore that happened
in royal Maine when they stumbled upon
the corpse of a woman who had gone
missing months before she was tall woman
the autopsy reported that she was
extremely malnourished however her cause
of death was from multiple stab wounds
in a cervical fracture police were never
able to find the killer the next year
police walled off the facility the site
is very popular with urban explorers and
paranormal investigators alike some tell
tales of seeing the murdered woman
others here screams emanating from the
inner parts of the building tonight you
are going to prove whether or not these
rumors are true equipped with nothing
more than a digital camera and a
flashlight you scale the wall oh no no
no so that was just the intro huh no
it's just the intro huh all right cool
good job roar I can do that too but I
just don't feel like it does that be
weird for me to suddenly just start howl
in the middle of the woods alone
especially after I'm sneaking into a
place and I'm sure that all those other
urban explorers you know they probably
brought in digital cameras too why
didn't we just watch their footage huh
unless they didn't make it out alive
which would be a problem for me no but
I'll make it this time I'm gonna survive
this is gonna be mine I'm gonna make it
all right
can you just cool it what exactly am I
looking for yeah yeah yeah barf yea barf
I forgot I could run I never even tried
to run before oh hello how are you
what wow whoa whoa what was that okay
I'm in I guess that's a big yes a big
honking that's a big honker that's a big
old honker um
so I'm sorry what I'm I apologize what
okay so I came in someplace with a
crawlspace I mean I either came in from
the top left ha boy [ __ ] was that
don't you screw with me ah okay I think
I must be coming in from the top left
that that's the only thing that makes
sense to me right now
oh so this just goes back into that
hallway I imagine this is just a way to
get out of his path when he comes
barreling down at me I don't know if
these things are safe but they feel
better than just wandering was it a part
a part anymore
oh hi okay yeah you are a thing okay you
are a thing are you snapping I'm just
gonna go for it
he's going for it just going for it
going for it going for it going for it
going for it I need an orange key to
open this that's weird and doom like
okay alright orange key I need an Orange
Julius so there's some kind of an orange
key I don't know why I don't know why I
need an orange key but I do need an
orange key apparently so they're gonna
be like an announcement when he comes by
or am I just going to be royally boned
oh this is just a running away loop this
is just a runaway loop that's just a
loop to run away I gotta stop using the
flashlight in long mode long mode is
gonna get me killed because I'm not
gonna see him in front of my face or her
I think I just got to look around till I
find orange okay okay I think I made it
now okay I wish I could point it out to
you but I'm like a second group of rooms
bought up from the bottom left in the
third room with the yellow dot in the
middle of it oh yeah this is terrifying
I mean this captures the one thing that
I love about horror games which is
apprehension avert
it's a very important it's a very
important quality about horror games
apprehension the ability for a person
did not want to move forward because
they don't know what lurks around the
corner and they don't want to find out
that's a very important thing in horror
games that is missing in a lot of these
games I play these days it's just that
sense of apprehension it's just so
important okay I'm all the way bottom
right now I think I don't know what the
orange key looks like I'm guessing it's
orange so that's all I have to go on and
again I do not know if these little
things are safe but they feel good they
feel real good
okay I'm not quite full top right but
I'm close to top right I'm just trying
to search all the rooms I don't want it
why are you you're like a worse version
of Baldy you keep slapping stop it I
just don't know how am I ever gonna know
where he is there's like very subtle
sound cues besides the snap there's like
some subtle stuff that like anything
like that makes me think that
something's about to happen okay I do
wanna go I feel safe here
I feel small safe I feel tiny safe I
haven't seen anything I don't know what
it's gonna look like when I see it
hopefully I recognize they're not I see
if the thing is like I have no idea how
he behaves all I know is that he killed
me instantly last time and I haven't su
mning that's gonna happen the second he
sees me
it's not as much graffiti oh oh oh oh
where is it where's it where's it
where's oh God huh I'm a baby , I'm a
big [ __ ] baby okay there's a the only
other place I haven't checked is like
the middle section oh I hate this I
don't like I don't know I'm gonna
actually move over to this one cuz I
feel like I'll bet better be able to see
down the hallway this hallway here
specifically Oh God oh I thought that
was a body oh god where am I
okay Stan this way oh [ __ ] oh okay
some of these are unmarked little some
of these little alcoves are unmarked I
don't know
whoa what is that is that a thing that
might be a thing okay all right um I'm a
go for it I guess something in this
chest the key is in his chest what he's
what the kid is his chest whose just
what his chest okay I'm guessing you
mean like someone's chest cavity and I
don't know who you're talking about but
I don't want to know who you're talking
about
I think I'm in the room I think I'm in
the room second from the top left the
square there I just have no idea where
he is
so far so good
I just can't get too comfortable is the
thing I just can't get too comfortable
wait what happened what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what happened what I'm
sorry what what happened
why oh my god you have what what is
happening the [ __ ] is that what is it
what is happening I have no idea oh that
leaks down to the exit hallway I need to
I need to go out that and make a left or
something [ __ ] soap what are you
doing oh oh I know what's happening he's
walking by this hallway that I'm a Jason
is gonna happen again I bet no which
means he might have gone the other way I
guess it's every time he comes by this
hallway he gets close enough to trigger
that effect [ __ ] terrifying breath so
I don't know which way he went then I'm
gonna move left down here in here okay
good I don't know if this is good or bad
doesn't feel good but I gotta explore
these last few plays okay why Oh God
stop that stop it stop it you
consternated [ __ ] okay I haven't seen a
body or anything like that so I don't
know what they mean by Oh saw that you
have you have to stop that
you have to it's the law oh where am i
oh god where am i where am i oh god oh
no wait wait oh boy
okay that was a mistake okay oh it's a
big empty room okay was there something
in there there might have actually been
something in there Oh fine okay you're
fine you're fine you're fine he's going
that way so would unless he comes in
there where am I going I don't know oh
okay
all right um where am I I've kind of
lost my position here I don't know where
I am
god dammit okay um I don't think that
was okay this is the hallway that means
my god whoo nice pants nice pants nice
pants um I don't know where I am
um what room is that I don't know oh boy
he's mad he's grumpy he wants me can't
get me though
stupid oh god no that's not good okay
that's okay is he just on me now forever
can we go I'm a girl i'ma go
go I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm
going you can't get me cuz I'm going I
don't know where I'm going I've lost
myself again no boy I've lost I'm lost
I'm lost I don't know where I am
okay ah this is that hallway okay so if
this is that there's only a few other
places that I need to go to check can I
get down here
I'm gonna take a left ducking here okay
ah this is where he was chasing me right
okay no no no no no no no no no no we're
[Music]
nothing nothing nothing a lot of nothing
just nothing whole lot of nothing okay a
lot of nothing I think I've checked
everywhere I can't think of any other
place that I haven't checked says the
key to this chest is in his chest your
fur into the killer with the knife cuz I
don't know how I'm gonna get into that
just to be perfectly honest I don't know
how that's gonna happen but uh if that's
what you want I suppose I can tango if I
just keep wandering around eventually
I'm both gonna run into him and then
maybe running to something else I don't
know nothing nothing
and nothing nothing [ __ ] god dammit
stop that [ __ ] cure over there which is
good cause that gives me time to look
over here oh my god you gotta stop doing
that man you gotta stop doing that
there's not cool there's a million times
not cool man you gotta stop so uncool so
very uncool oh [ __ ] okay I'm just going
for it
I don't know how okay did I get away am
I faster than you is that what I'm
understanding about this equation is
that I'm faster than you come on
Oh God okay I don't know where that was
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know he may he boy he
he he's my head he's mad he's mad okay
all right I don't know where I am but
okay but now that I know I can kind of
run away from him that makes it a little
bit better now I don't need to be so
skittish ceci anticipation that kills
you it's just like it's the reluctance
it's the apprehension that's what I said
that's a big word I used it's the
apprehension that really gets to you
it's not like that there's a monster
that makes it scary it's that there's a
monster that you don't know what it can
do that's scary that's what really
scares people
oh hi okay goodbye I've looked through
these before I've looked through all
this before I've looked through all of
this every nook every cranny I've looked
through these yeah the key is in H is
chest
what does does that have any significant
H is chest is that like significant in a
way where okay I'm just gonna turn this
on because I haven't used it at all
TomSka okay that's not good man they
really want to do that okay cool good
good to know
[Applause]
just a use this cuz I haven't and I'm
just gonna yeah I see nothing I see so
much nothing just a whole lot of nothing
a whopping heaping helping of nothing oh
hey bud just a big ol butt donk a donk
of nothing is the graffiti any hint a
helpful hint into who can I get out the
hell the door won't up what the hell oh
man you had a lot more of this than I
thought you did I hope I'm not just
wasting it all here I definitely might
be wasting this cuz if there's more game
after this then oh there oh hi um find
and find a knife find a knot how did I
miss that
oh god how did I miss that okay find a
knife oh where am I gonna what the hell
wait what the body's gone wait what oh
it didn't spawn it oh that's dumb
that's dumb okay so find a knife we're
am I gonna find a knife okay all right I
guess more running then I can't believe
that that was right I've walked by that
so many times and I haven't seen a knife
anywhere where's a knife
whoa hey buddy sorry you caught me with
my pants down whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey whoa whoa whoa stop that
stop it how do I get out of here oh geez
okay well I was gonna go that way but I
guess not anymore cool great thank you
thank you for that I don't know where I
am I don't know where I'm going
knife knife knife knife knife knife
knife anybody got a knife knife anybody
knife knife knife somebody knife me I'm
gonna throw me a knife whoa
there's that snapping again hello hey
how are you Wow stop that nonsense what
are you doing no no no no what you doing
where you going and it disappeared what
what just happened
where'd you go do you like morph into a
different part of it so we can randomly
appear anywhere in the map I'm almost
out of looking juice I mean he's got a
knife I don't know how to get a knife
from him I don't think he's willing to
give me a knife I mean he's willing to
give me the knife but only temporarily
and in not in my hand Oh what really oh
you're gonna do it like that okay found
a knife that was not there before that
was definitely not there okay so if I
remember where the body was found the
chest key okay high chest key get it
it's funny okay I think I go back now
would not be a good time to suddenly run
into him like a [ __ ] right here
found orange door key okay good now I
just have to make it out and down I'm
being cautious because I don't want to
ruin it right at the end I [ __ ] he's
near okay where are you
there's a door right there that leads
straight down to it by [ __ ] god damn
it is he gonna go by that door where is
he
goddammit okay you didn't go by that
door which leads me to believe that he's
not coming down that way
so I should be good going down here
straight down good yep I'm good I got
this game easy oh you know you've got to
be kidding me there's more really
there's more oh my god okay well great
okay good great oh my god that's huge
that's so big big and beefy alright well
it's gonna take a lot more running I
guess um huh I don't even know where I
came in
is there even a way out of here oh I see
it okay I am not on a percent sure where
I came in
I really don't know I I got a green or
but that's good I guess
Wow I got a green orb what does that
mean I wasted all of my seeing juice and
I I've got no more I've got no way to
replenish it okay oh boy oh boy
containers dead ends great good great oh
boy so now I can't hide in those nooks
or the crannies oh okay can't through
this lock doesn't use keys okay so
there's got to be like a switch or
something something that needs an orb I
need to look at my map for just a second
I need to find a place to rest my eyes
my weary oh wait did I already make a
circle no there's no um I have no idea
where I am I think those containers were
on the top right cuz I would make sense
if the door was over there and then I
came in over there okay oh oh God stop
that stop it stop are you the only thing
in here I think both of them are in here
for some reason oh I should have known
that it was just easy mode before I
should have known I have no idea what
I'm I have no idea why or how I'm gonna
get whatever I need to get I have no
idea it's just so labyrinthian
these are the same containers I think or
these are the different containers
there's two container sections judging
by what's on the map here this is the
more regular one with an outside route
so it must be the other container so
there anything in here that I need
anything useful
not by the looks of it I don't know why
but I'm alive and I don't know how and I
don't know why but I'm alive oh boy oh
boy ooh big bongos oh great big bazongas
great big bangle ooga lose Oh huge
honkin bazongas okay I think I know
where I am surprisingly yeah okay
there's no reason to go back I think
there might be a reason why why why why
oh you must have been closer than I
would have liked I think that thing just
goes right through walls which is fine
because hey I like to do that too I just
happen to go under him pause real quick
I need to look I have no idea where I am
okay that look was useless because I
have no idea where I am
oh but oh hi bud okay that's weird okay
oh hi bud okay that's weird don't come
back
maybe gosh oh my
could we not do that could we not do
that that is something that we could not
do oh my goodness I have seen nothing
it's a big maze just a big freakin maze
and it's just gonna be pure happenstance
if I find something combing this thing
for hours and be lucky to find even one
thing that I need a little own - I mean
I came across a green orb which is
actually pretty impressive I think by
pure happenstance I found a green orb
which probably is very useful but I have
no idea where a green orb would go is
the thing trying to loop back a few
times I'm trying to loop back a few
times so that I make sure I don't miss
anything trying to make big sweeping
paths across this [ __ ] was that about I
haven't there's a special oh I did it oh
god there's three orbs okay so this is
by alright so I need to find more orbs
now judging by how the last thing went I
think the orbs must spawn in when you
find one and then another right that's
got to be it but now I know where to
deliver them so I need to find two more
orbs oh god you got to stop that man you
got to stop it you've got to stop that
that is no bueno right why where where
where what oh god I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm
I'm dead I'm so bad I'm so good I'm dead
I'm not dead oh I think I saw it popping
out of the wall there that was good I
was comforting oh hi Wow you are awful I
hate you know what
oh it just sends me back to the
beginning
what with no progress or what why what
happened where are you oh okay yeah
that's it you just cuz you send me back
that's it
sock came over I miss kind of game over
right maybe it resets my progress I
don't know weird my night vision is
still gone though so it's like a soft
reset I guess oh no it resets my
progress oh god damn it
okay well [ __ ] god damn that's intense
you know I've uh man I've been doing
this for like an hour now I've no like I
have no idea how long it would take me
to get through this but I'm gonna end
this for now and just say holy [ __ ] that
was really scary it's lost some of its
care now then I know it's not too much
of a threat but that was still very very
terrifying at first I may revisit this
at some point since I ran out of time
for this episode but thank you everybody
so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below if you want to play this
for yourself and have your what took is
scared off I'll put a link in the
description really good stuff though so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see consternation one
I'll link it in the description whose
many years ago but still very good so
thanks again now as always I'll see you
bye-bye
[Music]